[Music]
we are living in very interesting times
and let me tell you why because in the
next five 10 15 years a lot of jobs
today industries and businesses today
are going to be extinct and this is so
scary for the bigger companies up there
but it's so exciting for the smaller
nimble companies and entrepreneurs that
are coming up why here's why because
we're about five 10 15 years away from
somebody coming out with an idea after a
major disruption where someone's going
to be called a trillionaire not a
billionaire in the next 5 10 15 years so
I'm gonna give you a lot of different
industries that are about to go extinct
and I'll put the given out the ones that
everybody knows about I'm not covering
the ones that you heard many different
times such as you know publishers
newspapers magazines cashiers travel
agents manufacturing workers bank
tellers taxi drivers radio GPS I'm not
covering those I'm assuming you already
know those are gonna be extinct here
very soon I want to give some new ones
here that we haven't talked about before
in the past so let me get right into it
first business I think restaurant the
game of restaurants gonna change
dramatically now let me explain what I'm
not talking about I'm not talking
high-end restaurants why am I not
talking about high-end restaurants
because for as long as long as husband
and wives have kids they're gonna want
to step away from their kids and go to a
private place away from everybody that
knows the madness and sometimes the best
way to do it to do it it's just let's go
to a nice dinner let's go to a nice
restaurant I'm talking about a whole
different thing let me explain to what I
think we're headed towards I think this
is what's coming next
imagine you and your wife you and your
girlfriend you and your husband you and
your boyfriend our city and you're gonna
say babe I'm tired today I don't want to
cook really baby you want to go to a
restaurant I just don't want I just want
to stay at the house I just don't want
to go out okay so what do you want you
want to order some takeout no I kind of
want some real food some really good
food babe I don't know what do you want
to do why don't we hire a chef so hiring
the chef used to be for the rich right
like you remember how the rich people
had drivers you know who has drivers
today everybody has the drivers called
an uber driver you don't need to be a
millionaire to have a driver in the 90s
one you said my driver will be picking
me up oh my gosh that's a rich man
right there not today today chefs I have
my own chef no one's gonna care if you
got your own ship in the next couple
years because you're gonna get on an app
what do you feel like eating baby I feel
like sushi
okay great there's this chef here that's
a four and a half star 328 reviews and I
checked this availability it's available
tonight between 6:00 and 8:00 should we
book him
what's his rate $25 an hour booking baby
boom boom boom great and there's a tip
he goes he buys the food he comes to
your house cooks everything fresh for
you in your house and this app is gonna
do a background check on the person
who's a chef just like an uber driver is
gonna do background check they're gonna
do a background check they will cook for
you you'll sit there you'll eat a good
fresh meal cooked by a chef and you're
gonna stay home and watch your movie and
not go anywhere someone's gonna serve it
to you and then you're gonna say oh my
gosh this was great what do you want to
do next weekend babe same thing do you
want to go to a restaurant no I believe
a model like that some of you are
watching this in oh my gosh has anybody
come out with it possibly in small
pockets but there's obviously not a big
one nationwide that everybody's using
when someone comes out with this they
will disrupt restaurant business in ways
that fast food all these guys are gonna
feel it immediately you know why because
what's the negative reputation of fast
food restaurants have it's the fact that
it's not healthy you mean to tell me I
can have a chef come to my house and
he's cooking healthy food and I don't
need to go anywhere
yes bring the chef babe everyone's gonna
have a chef I think that's the direction
we're going with restaurants number two
is movie theaters movie theaters are
about to get their tails handed to them
here's why I'll just give me some data
before I make my prediction back in 2009
just go do the research here back in
2009 in America 1 point 4 1 billion
tickets were sold to the movies in a
year 1 point 4 1 billion tickets were
sold which means 300 million there's
some kids involved give or take we go to
five movies per year on average as
Americans 1.4 billion tickets were sold
you know how many tickets were sold in
2017 last year 1.2 billion I'll have the
exact data here on the screen for you to
see it one point two three billion
tickets were sold last so we dropped 200
million tickets in only eight years and
it's gonna get worse because all these
buildings these standalone theaters that
are empty theaters empty theaters all
over the place that you're going to
they're gonna get crushed we like to sit
home and watch movies nowadays we have
and we have stuff that we can watch on
well we don't have to go anywhere to see
it it's getting more expensive people
are trying to charge it higher again the
high-end ones will do okay just like
high-end restaurants because it'll
become an experience but we're going a
completely different direction with
movie theaters and if they don't figure
out a way to pivot and adjust they're
gonna take a massive hit here coming
soon
next one telecommunication this one some
of you guys will be confused but listen
we no longer have house phones yes we no
longer have car phones you agree soon we
will not be having any more smartphones
now you may say Pat you are out of your
mind if you think we're now gonna have a
smartphone can I ask you why you're
paying $100 a month for your phone
number why
can somebody Skype you for free yes do
you need a phone number for someone to
Skype you know do you need a phone
number for somebody to Facebook you from
all over well my friend call me from
Brussels today for free on Facebook
right do you need a phone number for
somebody to call you on snapchat no what
is my point why are we paying these
telecommunication companies $100 a month
for what if you want to call me call me
on my facebook line if you got five
hundred names on your phone don't your
five hundred people on Facebook have
your name aren't friends with you
anyways so if they need to call you they
can easily call you we don't need that
anymore see here's what I happen that I
want to be going away because you will
need this device to log on a social
media Facebook all this other stuff yeah
you'll pay 40 bucks a month for this you
pay twenty bucks a month for data why
are we paying $150 a month for phones
there are about to get hit in a major
way in the next five 10 15 years once
somebody figures this things out and
remember what I said this June 2018
once someone figures that everyone's
gonna say why do I have a phone number
go ask after I explain it to you right
now you're watching us ask your friends
today all day why don't we have a phone
number just ask him and tell him exactly
what I told you see your friends
reaction what they're gonna say you know
what I never thought about it why are we
paying $100 why we paid $80 why would
pay $90 this is another disruptions
that's about to take place next one cars
Morgan Stanley just came out today
Morgan Stanley just came out and this is
what they said they said General Motors
should stop making cars in North America
because there currently were negative
four billion dollars why look you know
people say everything is getting more
expensive believe it or not a lot of
things are getting cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper telephones gonna be cheaper
okay a lot of things are getting cheaper
if you really if you really think about
it
a lot of things are becoming free you
kind of have to give things away for
free
there used to be time we have to pay a
lot of money for softwares how many
software's today are free based on just
Google and all these other things that
we have access to cars about are about
to take a big hit because one this whole
transportation deal will was taking
place again high-end cars will be around
because rich people want to be able to
show with status and look at my one
million dollar car that I have here enzo
or one million dollar two million dollar
Bugatti I have your look in my Pagani
look at all these cars that's okay but
the regular day-to-day cars we're not
gonna need it anymore someone's gonna
pick you up you'll be transported
somewhere but the whole thing about
having two three four cars and a family
like we used to that is going to be
changing completely soon in the next
five 10 15 years I'm telling you that is
the direction we're going I may be wrong
but that's what I believe that's the
direction we're going with that next one
I'll keep giving you simple on wallets
we used to have photo albums we no
longer have photo albums we just go on
Instagram and Facebook this wallet that
is $300 by Gucci Gucci guess what you
got to stop making wallets because these
things are going out of business we no
longer need wallets I know people are
making phone cases louisvil tongs got
phone cases all this other stuff wallets
gone retailers next one I really feel
bad for Walmart let me tell you why I
like Walmart the reason why I have
affinity to Walmart because when I was
living in Kentucky in this city that had
no nightclubs and I'm 18 years old on
Friday nights you know what we would go
to meet girls we'd go to Walmart to meet
girls our night club was called Walmart
so I have some kind of an affinity to
Walmart but Walmart there's a business
out there okay that's called Amazon
that's the closest thing to a monopoly
today and the president knows it's a
monopoly he's trying to push it for
monopoly a lot of people are trying to
push it for monopoly and if you think
Bayes
being worth 120 billion dollars is a lot
of money wait till over the next couple
of years all of a sudden he's worth 300
billion in no time because Amazon is not
Sloane then Amazon is one of the most
dangerous companies in the world to
competitors competitors go to sleep when
they watch a movie with the Amazon River
they shimmer and have nightmares all
night long because all they know is this
company's about to take their market
place away from them these retailers are
becoming showrooms what do we need a
showroom for there's simply help in
Amazon you're going to Walmart you're
taking a picture then you go into Amazon
you're paying something 20% cheaper
Amazon is helping one Walmart is helping
Amazon Walmart has become Amazon's
showroom how pathetic is that how many
times have you gone to a store you
looked at something you took a picture
you want online a bottle from Amazon how
many times have you done it we do it all
the time what is the point the point is
these showroom businesses that ran out
all this massive space it's gonna be
going away because first of all you're
not gonna be doing shopping anyways it's
gonna be a what do you call a warehouse
type of deal someone's gonna go shop for
you they're gonna be everything's gonna
be someone's gonna do to income these
are jobs sure someone's gonna go and do
it for them bring you to I'm on this
stuff I'm gonna go buy it and bring it
to you this is the kind of direction
we're going out so this showroom type of
stuff you're only helping out of
business like Amazon oh next one this is
the one industry that I am a part of it
let me tell you what industry this is
this is the insurance industry listen up
insurance industry whether you're a P&C
Property and Casualty life or whatever
it is look underwriters if you're an
underwriter and you're watching this
hurry up and figure out a way to become
an analyst not an underwriter let me
explain to why if I am hiring you and I
want an analyst and I see that you've
been an underwriter your last job was an
underwriter it's already too late for
you I would be hurrying up and becoming
an analyst very quickly and this is why
look underwriters get paid a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year
underwriters go to very good schools
they're great with math actuaries they
have they study statistics are
phenomenal with numbers but they have
positioned themselves in the wrong place
because if I'm running an insurance
company as a carrier not the one that's
selling it as the
carrier I am investing currently today
to the best kids coming out of Wharton
Business School who were ridiculous in
math who were ridiculous in analytics
who were ridiculous in data I'm hiring
every one of these young cats and I'm
bringing them and I'm telling them
figure out a way for me to make the cost
of insurance be different on this figure
out a way for me to be able to maximize
this without needing any underwriters
because I'm eliminating another cost to
me as a company and that's exactly
another direction will be going
underwriters will be gone and
underwriters mind will be replaced by a
machine you're very very soon next next
is journalists traditional journalists
are going away listen this whole thing
about the amount of credibility
journalists have today social media has
hurt journalists all these WordPress the
blogs all these websites where you can
go out and share your opinion they're
hurting journalists now some people are
saying well it doesn't yet heard you her
journal is because the best ones are
coming up let me give you an example of
what I mean by the best one micro micro
post something on his website it gets
hundreds of thousands of shares he
doesn't need to work for somebody his
website brings so much traffic that a
business would be willing to advertise
on his website for $50,000 $100,000 a
month the guy's making a million dollars
here just on endorsements that he's
getting why do I need to go be a
journalist and tie my name to New York
Times or LA Times or any of that stuff
the only reason these magazines and
newspapers are gonna be around is
because a billionaire is gonna come and
buy Washington Post also known as
Amazon's owner which is who Jeff Bezos
he owns Washington Post because I need
to make sure I also control media a
little bit another billionaire today
just bought LA Times just today LA Times
was just bought for only 500 million
dollars he thinks for business purely
for influence you may buy because you
want to control media but you're not
buying it because you're trying to make
money off of it it's gonna be completed
from purpose for buying media not when
you and I are thinking about so
journalism is gonna be changing
tremendously next college sports which
one is a business college or sports okay
so check this out college sports which
is a business college or sports you may
say both okay great
they're both businesses which one relies
on the other one again which relies on
the other one what do you mean Pat
without which one is there not the other
one
I don't know well sports relies on what
colleges stay with me here this is gonna
get a little crazy which one makes them
a lot of money a lot of attention sports
brings them billions of dollars to these
schools so they have to make sure the
college stays in business because if
colleges don't stay in business they
don't have all this free money that's
coming in to them because they're not
paying these athletes right here's what
I think is gonna take place this one's
gonna be a strange one and I'm gonna
give a compliment to a very weird person
Lavar ball
Lavar ball right now is going around the
nation and he's asking and tweeting out
an Instagram any great ballers in
Chicago Agis this to this come on down
are we gonna do with this listen he may
be crazy but if there's somebody that's
watching this right now saying where's
an opportunity for a league like a UFC
I'm gonna tell you something here right
now if somebody can create a national
league a national league for kids
between ages of 14 to 18 and a national
league that competes with major league
sports 18 to 20 I am even though right
now a lot of young kids go play for base
go play for a basketball they go early
and you see some of them have to be a
little bit longer for them to go in I
think there's a big opportunity right
now for sports that doesn't have to do
with colleges it's just sports a level
below the NBA a level below the NFL a
level below that that young cats are
coming up and I'm not even talking about
d-league or any of this stuff I'm
talking about a real league where money
is being made if someone can figure out
a way to do that without colleges being
needed because colleges are going away
kids are not gonna be going to college
the way we've been going to college it's
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and becoming a bigger and bigger
business and people are starting to
realize and read between the BS that a
four-year degree doesn't give me
anything because things are changing so
rapidly I wrote a book on this called
dropout and get school and I got a ton
of hate on it how can you write a book
called dropout and get to school but
here's the thing
I'm a dropout I didn't graduate college
I don't have a four-year or two-year
degree well pay you don't have the right
to write a book like that I don't write
about myself I wrote it with a guy named
Thomas L sward who got a four-year
degree and has got a masters and was a
professor at UCLA and by
and pepper then we both wrote it
together and gave different views on why
it's time to drop out and get school and
why I believe 80% of college students
shouldn't go to college
this thing's gonna change but this
doesn't mean that there is not an
opportunity for some other to go figure
out a way to do things with sports next
one is gonna be gas stations obviously
gas stations are gonna be gone very
quickly this whole gas business in the
80s and 90s I'm Middle Eastern one of
the things about Middle Easterners we
own a lot of gas stations it's easy you
bring them on your bike at stations it's
like an annuity pays you on a monthly
basis and it's pretty good amounts
depending on how to market that so we
don't mind that we like gas stations but
it's gonna change investing in gas
stations today is a bad idea let me give
you the last point here politics this
may not have to do with money but it
does let me explain to what I mean by
politics this is the thing about
politics first of all I don't agree with
our current voting system that we have
and the reason why I don't believe with
the current voting system that we have
is the following reason let me explain
something to you say I'm a 14 year old
kid okay say I blow up because I'm sexy
as hell okay hypothetically I look so
good and and and you know I'm disruptive
I'm crazy and I'm interesting and all of
a sudden I have a hundred and forty five
million people following me okay
and I grow up and I have some opinions I
have some thoughts and I'm very
persuasive and I'm very good with
communication and putting words together
because I'm an artist or whatever I am
and I start talking about some
correcting and injustice we are very
soon going to be seen at 35 36 your
president in the United States of
America very very soon we will be having
at 35 36 your president and if it's only
based on who has the biggest
followership and I try to figure out a
way to minimize the debates debates as
much as possible because if I'm good at
what I do I'll minimize the debates to
the least amount that I have to be a
part of to participate as a person
that's registered to run for president
and if I can do my videos well and I say
I don't come to debates you want to
debate me I do it Facebook live that's
the only way I do it I don't come to
physical debates somebody is gonna see
this and they're gonna say wait a minute
but you have to come to the debate no I
don't it never said I have to do this or
cry tears well you have to come to these
I'll come to those but if you want to
vote for me vote for me and then all of
a sudden we have a president that not
knowingly may not be the best thing for
us but we just voted for somebody
politics is about to change in a major
way I'm
right now you're gonna see political if
you think this last political campaign
was crazy with Twitter you really think
this was crazy that was done by 69 year
old man wait til it's done by 36 year
old person that knows everything about
social media everything about all these
BOTS and everything we're facing and by
the way I'm not talking about just
manipulation I'm not talking I'm talking
about a marketer that's kind of come and
disrupt the entire political game very
and bother what's gonna happen at the
lower levels very easy Congress mayor
all that stuff senator nope I'm talking
at the highest level which means the
president so there's a big opportunity
there but there's also attention to be
paid to the political side and not just
be too naive just because somebody's got
a lot of following to go out and pull
that off because very soon you will see
candidate in America a 35/36 or that's
gonna say I want to be the president
United States now that's how to set up
is I don't want a lot of my American
patriots that come and say you know you
stop trying to change this I'm not
trying to change all that stuff I'm just
telling you Bo where were you where you
got to adapt you've got a pivot you
gotta just because if you don't you're
gonna be the one that's gonna suffer the
consequences
I'm simply making you aware and by the
way I am very comfortable being wrong
with every single one of the predictions
that I made but I don't think I'm wrong
with every one of them having said that
again questions thoughts comment below
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
click right here to subscribe to the
channel as well and by the way we have a
PDF on this as well below they can
download click on the link below for you
to download the PDF that Mario's
prepared for you take everybody